sorry to tell you that there's too much
power in the hands of the special
interest there's too much power by
people who are lobbyists and campaign
contributors and and members of Congress
who are beholding those special
interests which has given us the Iron
Triangle and given us a situation that
Dwight David Eisenhower warned us about
many years ago in his farewell speech
and that is the military-industrial
complex and their influence and control
over policies as well as the use of
taxpayers dollars so i would have to say
that the special interests have too much
influence the real power still will
reside in the President on states of
that President can maintain the approval
of the American people if that present
can do that that president can be the
most powerful person in Washington and
in the world well I would expose every
pork barrel bill that came across my
desk I would make the authors of it
famous I would point out who the special
interests are and I would hammer them on
a daily basis and I would break their
grip and i would start acting in the
interests of the American people who
don't have paid lobbyists here in
Washington or the influence that that
some special interests have and finally
I'd restore trust and confidence in
government so that the people would
believe me when I could tell them what
wasteful and unnecessary and even
member